ever feel like you just cannot keep up with the crumbs the kids make
this is the perfect vacuum for that
it's super easy for the kids to pick up their own mess
I keep it right in the pantry
where it's easy accessible for everyone in the family
so when they make a mess they can just grab it real quick
it's battery power
so it's easy just to click that trigger and go here
I'm just cleaning up some mess I made
baking some sourdough bread right before I went to bed
it picked up flour and crumbs beautifully
it seems to work on hardwood floors great
I'm not sure about high pile carpets cause I have rugable carpets
which I absolutely love
I have rugable carpets in several places in my house
and I hate where a regular vacuum will suck on it so hard that it will like
rip the carpets up and make them peel and wrinkle up
and I have to re put them back down
this vacuum has the perfect amount of suction to clean the rugable rugs
it comes with a lithium battery and charger
the battery lasts long enough to give my whole home a quick
light vacuum just picking up crumbs
it also has a really small head on it so you can fit into really tight spaces
especially around the toilet
and other spots where my other vacuum just won't reach
I also really like the light on the front
I like the shower
illuminates me dust and hair so you can see where to go
right now there's some flash out for only 89 99
go get yours today
free shipping enjoy